this year saw a surprising pick for the
German book prize author frank Witsel
was an outsider on the short list he won
the award for a truly monumental work we
caught up with him at the book fair
Pulitzer has been catapulted into the
spotlight he's not used to being the
focus of so much attention even though
at 60 he's hardly a newcomer the winning
book is his third novel he also writes
poetry and essays but this has been an
exceptional experience
from vitz Leah congratulations on
winning the 2015 german book prize thank
you for ya the absolute all you have is
it not me but I've never witnessed such
across-the-board excitement about a book
prize winner are you still in shock how
was it a cycle of him yeah whatever I
love feeling done yes but I'm over it
now and thanks for your best wishes the
excitement really was palpable at the
award ceremony in Frankfurt City Hall it
was overwhelming I myself only felt I
had an outside chance so I wasn't
expecting it but then I was swept up on
this wave of jubilation that's wonderful
guns soil the invention of the Red Army
Faction by a manic-depressive teenager
in the summer of nineteen sixty-nine
it's a brick of a book to call this 800
page epica coming-of-age novel wouldn't
do it justice it's a portrait of a
generation a hall of mirrors was
shifting time and perspective usually
hutton woman woulda had in a book on the
jerry talked about the novel as daring
did you know from the start where you
wanted to take it garnish no not at all
I started out simply wanting to capture
an atmosphere I knew from the start I
didn't want to use just one perspective
to just tell the story of a teenager my
aim was to capture a mood see I knew I
wanted to somehow with circle around it
d not so I know our dome kaisan
thirteen-year-old tmills world is
stifling growing up in wiesbaden in the
sticks of West Germany his life consists
of school sports club family and the
Catholic Church society is conservative
and hidebound still overshadowed by the
Second World War
but the first stirrings of discontent
are palpable a discontent that will
alter the country for good Teemo found
again he calls the Red Army Faction
copying the logo from his sports club
he's not worried about the terrorist
attacks perpetrated by another Red Army
Faction the baader-meinhof gang ron d
zeta gossip today the novel is set in
the 1960s and 70s was this a special
time and or a terrible times what I was
when you like it so far it was anything
but romantic there was nothing glamorous
about the Red Army Faction its glamour
worse test the country was gripped by a
bleak letting sense of Trenton a target
of course there was a coziness there two
pockets of safety beauty it was
structured simple modest fog but in
other ways he was very oppressive and
claustrophobic line of a Tyler visor
essence we shall see but we can see I
named pan pizza spent 15 years working
on his novel 15 years finding out how he
wanted to tell his story but it wasn't
all he worked on he wrote poetry and
essays also composed music and worked as
an illustrator
but the novel was always at the back of
his mind it is a huge pain in a lot of
critics are saying your novel is your
masterpiece your magnum opus are they
right yeah yeah it's just saw yeah yes
that's what it is does it's not a school
bus ride it's a bit strange because I
don't want to say right that was it and
there still is a lot I'd like to write
about and I'm already working on
something I've also me the other vitae
timati but because the subject matter of
this book is so close to my heart it's
um and also because it ended up so large
i would say yes this is my magnum opus
oh I'll never write a book like this one
again so I'm delighted that it's been
received as a major novel the hostess
Tara water that's what mitrice's we
asked on Twitter to illustrate how he
felt when his name was announced
he draws us a picture expressing his
amazement
it still hasn't subsided the foreign
rights to his novel have been sold
worldwide his work of what the jury
called speculative realism seems to have
captured that site Geist
you